foreign
let's just say there's something like
Iron Chef for tabletop games if you want
if you want that you can run with it
I'll take my customer 15 so it's like
the unveiling of the components let's
just say which would be some constraints
I'm not going to give you specific ones
but let's just say you yourself kind of
locked in a room like old school
Japanese manga artists this would happen
like the Publishers would be like you
need to finish X number of issues like
we're gonna keep you fed but you're
going to be in a room until you finish
yeah yeah right yeah but let's just say
that you had
a week to design a game okay
you you're allowed to have some play
testers come in for like the second half
of the week generous of you thank you
you're welcome I'm a very lenient
dictator I'm known as the thoughtful
Warden
how would you personally approach it
like you can have pen and paper and all
of the mock-up materials that you need
yeah
how would you go about it first of all
you don't need much more than pen and
paper honestly like that's it so the way
I would go about it is I would say
okay given this maybe these blank cards
and these Sharpie pens which I travel
around with everywhere like that is all
my bag is filled with and blank cards
you mean like a plan yeah like poker
cards stack of cards white on both sides
yeah where do you get those Amazon uh
literally I ordered them by the palette
at this point it's nuts
because they're so cool right like you
need to design a game you got the cards
you need dice I don't have dice great
I'll take six cards right one two three
four five six shuffle them up draw a
card hey you got dice right like they're
everything they're absolutely everything
so the first thing I would look for is
like what can I do with these very
simple components that creates a core
gameplay Loop that I'm excited about
and I can I can rattle off 12 of those
in an hour that's that's honestly not
the hard part 12 different gameplay
Loops that you're familiar with that I'm
excited about that I can just invent
they're not that hard it's like okay
I'm gonna give
you a card and I'm Gonna Keep a card and
whoever has the highest card wins but
first we're gonna have a conversation
and we're I'm making this up as I go I'm
gonna try to Bluff you like I'm going to
try to get you to discard your card
because you don't think there's any
chance you can win and you can or still
earn a little bit if I can get you to
fold right right those are easy and come
up with a ton of those and again you
notice
the Crux of that was we're entertaining
each other the conversation is actually
the game the cards don't matter
that's just my Mantra over and over and
over again yep so we do that come up
with a bunch of those and then I need
another person I need at least one
person that I can show these two play
the games with and I only care about one
question in fact we do all these play
tests we don't even give out surveys
anymore there's only one question we ask
which is when you finish playing the
game did you want to play again
and a game is done when 100 of people
say yes
and it never starts that way it's always
a whole bunch of no's and let me tell
you why and all that stuff but
but that's the only question I care
about
when you finish did you want to play
again and if I can get a little bit of
positive feedback there from a person
showing a bunch of Concepts too and one
of them they say oh let's play that one
again
then you got to start thinking about
okay why do they want to play that again
well maybe they had so much fun they
wanted to play again maybe they thought
they could do better the second time
kind of a sense of Mastery that maybe
they could achieve by playing again and
I try to identify what that thing is
what that compelling that thing that
kept pulling them back in and double
down on that right that's that's the
thing I want to shine most in the game
start building the surrounding
components all to emphasize that thing
over and over and over again
and then generously you let me have play
testers at the end I'll start showing it
to them that is the point where I've got
my components are done my core gameplay
Loop is done I've got a few of the
peripheral things that are starting
to get those cylinders to fire now let
me put it through the paces and see what
people think
okay so let's say day one yeah so day
one you get you get seated and you're
comfortable yet not too comfortable sell
you have this like hamster bottle full
of coffee good I love it you got
unlimited Ramen and you have a table you
got your blank cards paper Sharpies
what is your brainstorming if that's the
right word to use look like right is it
questions right is it drawing cards
visually or otherwise is just you
sitting there staring at the wall kind
of running through things rehearsing
different things in your mind what would
that look like I think the way that I
approach that is I always imagine two of
me and when I have I need to physically
touch and hold things right so even if
the cards are blank I do need to like
hold six cards and Shuffle six cards and
and so if I'm holding them and I think
okay me standing in front of me
if I were to give you this thing what
conversation could we have it's I think
it's a lot like script writing like I
start with the conflict what is it
that's going to drive the conversation
we can't be getting along we can't have
the same motivation me handing this
thing to you better create a conflict
that now we're going to try to resolve
and that's really it
I think that's where all good ideas
start from is like here we are in a room
you know there can be only one so how
are we going to resolve that because
here we are staring at a bunch of blank
cards